so tonight I thought we would go over a
viewer submission it's been a while
since we've had to look at one of the
games that you guys have submitted and
you can still send them to me just go to
info at st. Louis chess club org and
send a game with a little description
perhaps your name and who knows could
end up on YouTube it was a particularly
beautiful game so when I saw it I just
felt like okay I got a got to show this
game and it actually reminded me of a
famous game so we're going to first take
a look at a famous game and we'll see
how the the amateur compared to the game
it was a really remarkable immortal game
and the theme for tonight is going to be
zoogs long which is of course when your
opponent is like obliged to move or you
or your opponent is obliged to move but
you really don't want to because any
move will make your position worse so
usually in chess you want to move
because you can improve your position
but there are rare cases they're a lot
more common in King and pawn end games
you know it's a particularly that occurs
quite a lot but it's not every day that
you see it with lots of pieces on the
board and somebody is just stuck for a
move they just any move they make their
position will deteriorate so it's really
rare that it happens with lots of pieces
on the board but somebody sent in such a
game and we're first going to jump over
here to the board and have a look at a
very famous game in which zoogs long was
employed with lots and lots of pieces on
the board this is the game between same
ish and nimzowitsch
from 1923 and copenhagen and it's often
referred to as the immortal Zhuge Liang
game
so we'll see it it will kind of hurry
through it we'll flip it around because
it's it's nimzowitsch is black so we're
going to kind of go through this because
we're going to focus on the
a gentleman's game and we'll read what
he has to say when we will we get to it
so night f3 so he's not allowing the
nimzo-indian with Bishop to b4 because
he's playing nimzowitsch and you know
you don't to play nimzo-indian against
nimzowitsch so instead we got a Queen's
Indian and 50 and shadow variation this
is all pretty typical and okay both
sides castle in the main move here today
is Knight to e4 but we're not going to
worry so much about the theory d5 also
very solid move and okay maybe we're
thinking about taking here the white
goes here so now this would be a blunder
because of the diagonal here so he's
preventing that and black just plays
another really solid move and E White
has the typical very small advantage
that he gets in the Queen's again and
here white actually made the first
positional mistake of the game and white
sort of played this game listless ly he
didn't really play with purpose he just
sort of did nothing which sometimes
works out sometimes the best thing to do
is not do anything at all it's hard to
know when to do that but you'll notice
he doesn't play very energetically and
he actually makes a mistake right here
he takes on d5 the tension in this
position actually really favors white
black is never really threatening to
take here not only do I have that
protected but also if you if you ever
take I mean you're going to get some
pressure here on c6
so it's positionally undesirable for
black to take and white can take at any
moment he chooses but choosing to do so
immediately is a mistake and it lets
black get a very solid position he just
takes back with the C pawn and now this
bishop that was sort of stuck defending
sort of an awkward pawn in the future he
might be able to go to a better diagonal
and he might also be able to do the plan
that he went through
in the game we'll have a look we'll give
away a move here in this plane here was
actually quite interesting so it's not
super obvious how black should proceed
in this position but his idea was to
gain more space on the queenside so he's
going to play a six b5 and in some
fashion he's going to try to maneuver a
knight to the c-4 square this is his his
middle game plan okay so he played a six
he played b5 queen VIII's of inria might
place a lot of ant moves that sort of
his thing so black is going to try to
put his Knight here on C for the pawn
structure really tells you kind of where
you want all of your pieces and there's
two routes to get there so you might
imagine d7 to b6 to c4 very possible in
the game he chose c6 which not only
gains a tempo on the D pawn but if okay
you just defend your pawn I'm going to
a5 with tempo and then I'm jumping into
c4 and okay that's just a good strategic
repositioning of my piece okay so gain
the tempo and white decided to trade the
Knights he didn't like the idea of the
night going to c4 and we reach this
position so there's some funny business
that could happen on this this file
you know you might imagine there's some
funny moves that that you can try but
you know okay we're just going to
protect our guy
it's no big deal so he decides instead
to play h3 so not doing a whole lot now
I quite like to move the black leg here
I think it's very good so what we'll
pause for a second now so what black
wants to do is he wants to play this
move b4 if he doesn't right away though
the knight is going to jump to a four
and then he's going to jump into c5 so
how did black prevent this idea I want
to play b4 but I don't want you to be
able to play Knight a4 how did he stop
them yeah good idea Queen d7 excellent
and that's exactly what he played so
yeah now where our idea is we're going
to play b4 and you won't have this
option so excellent all right until
white decided king h2 so he's sort of
stuck for a plan who doesn't really have
any real ambition here you can't guess
you can't figure out exactly what to do
it's it's not so easy and black does
have some plans to improve his position
you can imagine we played before our
Bishop gets to come to a nice square and
this Bishop that you know it's really
sort of an awkward piece in a lot of
lines if it does find yourself on this
diagonal it might actually turn out to
be a really strong piece okay and so
before he goes on with this plan of b4
which perfectly valid move here he
decides well not only do I want to win
on the queenside I want to win on the
Kings side as well so he plays the move
Knight h5
all right just threatening to take the
bishop achieve the bishop pair so the
bishop dropped back and now this move f5
alright so he gets sort of a stone wall
structure he's gaining lots more space
he's still going to play b4 things are
looking good so you'll notice black is
just improving his position white hasn't
been doing anything so it'll be be
interesting well what's going to happen
here now white decided to play the move
Queen to d1 so he's lining up the Queen
with the night so you can imagine we
might play III but we might also be
considering just playing e4 and you know
that might help us gain a tempo on the
night so that's his plan so black has to
take
pretty seriously but he has time to play
b4 and you'll notice that Knight doesn't
have a lot of places to go so the night
went back the only safe Square and again
we can prevent the the e4 idea for just
a moment Bishop to b5 white wants to
renew the idea so he moved his rook out
of the way and you might be thinking
simply okay you play Knight f6 or
something
but black actually played a really
really cunning move and I guess you can
pause if you want to try to play like a
name's a [ __ ] here but it's it's
difficult to appreciate until you see a
little bit deeper just how powerful this
move actually is it looks kind of like a
blunder Bishop d6 just ignoring the e4
idea so why why is this so good I mean
II four and all right as has black just
committed a huge blunder I mean now okay
even if well first of all you're you're
threatening to win this but also even if
I drop back well I'm getting forked so
how did black get himself out of this
bind what was this idea here let's see
if we can find a good move on to g6 seem
in pawn to g6 okay so I can either take
on d5 and also they can just play move
like this too
yes you could play this way and I mean
you know I don't think maybe it's not
all that special but maybe I don't want
a weekend all these squares in front of
my king you know I immediately
I'm sorry giving you access into my camp
a little bit
it could be playable but he didn't want
to weaken is his King side so okay but
that's a very good idea certainly a safe
way to play what's the ambitious smooth
clean f7 all right so everybody wants to
defend their stuff I think again I can
just play like 'if I've gained some
space okay I don't know that you have a
whole lot here you know so this this is
probably okay as well but he really had
a very very ambitious sacrifice here so
he went for the move F take c4
all right what's the idea all right I
take your night thank you and then what
did black play this hopefully is an easy
one
yeah
rook takes f2 exactly and okay let's
let's look at this for a second he gave
up a piece
what's this compensation he has two
pawns that's very good
and you'll start to notice what does
have certain issues it is particularly
difficult to play the white position
here the extra piece you have is this
Knight that at least at the moment
can't move anywhere not even there so
the knight of the stock you can't move
anywhere this this rook very active
piece all right I mean I'm just going to
continue I'm going to develop all my
pieces are going to come to very good
squares and okay how do you how do you
really play this as white so he was
thinking well first of all I want to get
out of this pin the pin is sort of a
nuisance if you just drop back right
away though you're dropping your Jeep on
so he proceeded to first defend his pawn
his next move is going to be king h1
getting out up in black just calmly
doubled up and as stated King to h1 and
you might be surprised to find that
white is actually completely losing here
so in this position you just simply
brought the rook up to f5 after he
dropped the Queen back another very
powerful move was played here what is it
so rookie to is a very tempting move
isn't it and so if you play here I mean
I have to move my queen so I move out of
the way and so this is definitely a part
of it and this I mean this must be great
for black you know I I don't even play
Bishop a5 but I might I just double who
knows so this is definitely a part of
the idea we want to threaten this but we
don't want the Queen to be able to run
away so what move did black play to
really contain the Queen
so yes see if we can find a very strong
move here yeah
Bishop c4 okay so I'll take it I'm not
going to get trapped so I have to avoid
getting trapped Bishop d3 yeah so this
is what was played yeah so now where's
the Queen going to go
I'm simply now threatening rookie to
trapping the Queen winning the game
so wipe defended and now remarkably one
more move was played and white resigned
and okay there's more than one move that
wins here but if you'll remember the
theme of Zuke's long you'll notice is
very difficult for white to move here so
a very calm move was played h6 and okay
white it's your turn and it's it's quite
remarkable
he absolutely doesn't have a move that
doesn't just immediately lose so he gave
it up here obviously we're having
difficulty getting our night out you
know we can't even drop the bishop back
because all the thing is the moment
because you take care you know okay we
can't move the rook away because then
rookie - we can't make a move like this
because of the bishop okay what about
this move though okay I mean okay we
can't move this bishop really either so
many reasons you just take I guess one
move to consider is what happens on King
h2o how does black just win here
okay you want to do this one let's
that's a good one to move it's not much
of a sacrifice because this guy's pinned
and there you can take one of these
things but your queen is trapped and
yeah so the bishop spins you can't even
take that way so this just wins pawn
moves don't do anything even if you play
move like this I mean I can just keep
the position the same all right your
your turn again so remarkably there's
just there's just nothing here okay I
mean if something like this we can just
keep going on there's just nothing to do
so you gave it up so I wanted to show
you guys this game really quick so that
we could appreciate this game that the
viewer submitted we will go ahead and
jump to that now and okay let's put the
first wheel on the board so this is the
reason that I wanted to show you guys
that game so we can see the similarities
in this game will be a little bit more
thorough with so there was a gentleman
named Philip Bloom who sent in this game
and what also was funny is I was just
looking at a bunch of games last night
to try to pick I thought I'd do a viewer
one and Ken West was there and he he
just started telling me the story about
what happened he just played the
tournament in Indianapolis and he said
oh yeah there's this guy named bloom and
I sat down next to him and he said hey
are you the real Ken West and he's like
yeah that's me and then somebody next to
him was like oh you're Ken West so yeah
so he's really famous ah but nobody
nobody knows what he looks like
you gotta come to the club to really see
him maybe we'll get him on the show one
day but he works Tuesday nights that's
the problem and so then you know so he
said yeah this guy bloom so I'm like was
it Philip Bloom and then I had it here
and he's like oh yeah that's the guy he
showed me this game so all right forgive
me it's it's a really really pretty game
really beautiful so I think ken west was
able to beat this guy so I don't know
his rating but it's he must be around
Ken West rating and this guy has sort of
the opposite problem with the game we
saw last week last week we saw a guy
that can play the opening like a genius
and
then you just blow it in the end game
tonight we're going to see you exactly
the opposite players didn't really play
optimal I mean okay they're not they're
not grandmasters that's excusable they
didn't play optimally and find all the
correct ways to punish black immediately
but uh okay the end is just so pretty
that we we really must take a look at it
and we'll read what this gentleman said
about the game he said this isn't the
strongest game you've ever seen but it
ended with a pretty remarkable Zubaz
long situation with a remarkable number
of amusing situations in between I don't
know if you've ever seen such a suit
long with so many pieces on the board
I played white correspondents game
against no-name and you know we know how
well no-name scores so doesn't look good
for him so I don't know whose opponent
is or what the rating is a time to
discover some crazy continuations and he
goes on a little bit okay so it starts
as an English will just jump through the
opening here though it quickly
transposed this to a King's Indian and
we have this sort of trendy move h3 it's
becoming sort of a popular move and so I
wanted the idea as well we do want to do
sometimes put our Bishop on e3 so we're
stopping any any Knight stuff and
sometimes we might be a little ambitious
and if black castles King side perhaps
will develop go the other way and maybe
will actually end up attacking black
which is sort of unusual in most Kings
Indians
so it's either is it a high-class
waiting move or is it just a waste of a
turn that's sort of the debate but some
pretty decent people have been playing
it lately so can't be so bad
h5 a novelty so this move is not good
for lots of reasons well I mean first of
all it just it's just weakening the
Kings side so perhaps I've been trying
to figure out why black played this this
move so it's never been played before
there's probably a reason
if black ever wants to castle now he
does have to consider that white will
play a
like g4 and try to open things up which
which makes it all really hard for black
to castle so already you know I guess h3
black Crawley had never seen this didn't
know what was going on so it has has
good surprise value and so we'll see
what happens so he just develops and
after a few more developing moves here
black makes a tremendous blunder that
goes unpunished b6 and surprisingly this
is already lost
well I can already punish black black is
making you know lots of moves on the
sides of the board he's not too
concerned with with cancelling so this
is kind of tricky though if you if you
haven't seen these types of positions
before so I will give the audience a
chance here we can pause at home how
could white have just won the game
outright and to give a small hint in
these types of positions well normally
the pawn is back here on h7 but what
black is doing is you know there
castling and they're playing either e5
or c5 in this position you need to take
some control of the center which you're
going to play this way so by avoiding
central play for a little bit too long
he's already in trouble here if white
plays correctly so hopefully that was a
big enough hint yeah II five so this is
the winning move so it doesn't matter if
you take on e5 or not
after some recapture alright we have to
drop back let's go to h7 so we can still
castle how do we continue this this
attack here already
see six
yes the sacrifice ecigs a very powerful
move the idea is to undermine the
kingside so if you take for example
these weaknesses are very bad news for
black
so either Queen c2 or Bishop to d3 are
both very good moves and it doesn't
matter how black attempts to hold on to
it you can put one of your your Knights
here but we're going to pile up on it
and it doesn't matter how you choose to
do this probably I Castle queenside but
something like this is actually really
really bad for black this it's just that
you're not going to last very long yeah
each five yeah I mean yeah here's a
little bit better even if we can take
our knife so yes that wasn't that wasn't
played so he didn't miss a chance and
this actually is something that happens
in there that Kings Indian so when
you're playing the King's Indian and
black doesn't attempt to make any stake
to the center you do want to be looking
for a move like 'if i've just to
immediately punish them and wipe them
off the board alright that wasn't played
instead this move d5 which are is it's
probably not the best move and i think
to white maybe he was thinking well
normally they attack my center and then
i play d5 but even though black hadn't
struck yet he's like I'll play d5 anyway
but really this also does give black
some additional squares that he might be
able to use so not not quite the correct
move but all right ah you know black
does some really funny maneuver you're
going to like this this maneuver now I
was trying to think why did black
retreat his Knight because it just looks
incredibly wrong and the only thing I
can think of is he's going to try to
damage White's pawn structure
you know computers like yeah that's fine
just do it but I mean it it doesn't know
we're gonna die no yeah all right so I
assumed even if you make a normal move
so this wasn't played in the game though
movie played the game was really strong
you know okay so you can do this it
doesn't seem like the human move but the
computers like yeah fine and the whole
I'll defend somehow is black here but
you know giving away the dark squares is
really scary because you know I'm coming
in and coming in so that's what I
thought maybe that's that's the only way
I can understand a move like this but uh
Knight d4 was played this is very strong
move and it has a very serious threat
because we know about smothered mate but
there's also the smothered queen so
we're just starting to win the Queen on
the spot and that does sort of force
black to play an awkward move that he
doesn't really want to play so in the
game he played Bishop to b7 the idea
being you're just guarding the c6 square
but unfortunately this is just a very
very bad square for the bishop I mean
because you're looking at a wall that
you're never going to break through so
that's always going to be a bad piece
and if you play the King's Indian a lot
normally what happens is you wait for
white to castle and then somehow you
take on h3 and you sacrifice everything
and you checkmate your opponent that's
what black likes to do so in a lot of
lines in the King's Indian
White is even willing to sacrifice upon
for positional compensation just to get
this guy off the board it's a very
common theme because this bishop wall
okay it doesn't look like he's doing too
much Wilson the pawn structure was was
fixed for a second fix all their pawns
this would be a typical thing you just
wait and wait and hopefully they play
the h3 so maybe one day we'll sack and
we'll take it well you're not going to
do that if you're not on that diagonal
and unfortunately our protagonist will
in the near future go ahead and go here
and let black get rid of this
this peace Queen due to okay normal and
you might think people are going to
Castle but people are never going to
Castle aha
so I guess he's like that this maneuver
was a failure he just jumps back
so obviously White has been out playing
his opponent but we're going to see
black is going to be a sort of a
resourceful guy and things are about to
change
so here white should just play like
Bishop e2 and maybe pick a side to
Castle Lee plays b4 which is probably
not the correct plan at this moment it's
typical that this is the idea you aim
for a move like c5 or something in this
this type of structure but it also gives
black the option of playing a move like
a 5 which causes some issues for white
because if you're forced to lock down
the Queen side this is exactly what
black is hoping to do he'll do lock down
the Queen side because that's usually
where you have more more counter play
because you have more space on the Queen
side so now you'll never open anything
up over there so this actually would be
quite the accomplishment for black and
then black can decide where to put the
King your castling queenside is now sort
of an idea but this actually would be a
really good move for black but black
didn't play a5 he went one Square too
short all right so not the best play but
at the end of the game that's what it's
that's what we're aiming for and out
here yeah he decided to jump in so this
was a mistake
you're giving away a great central piece
for I mean arguably blacks worst piece
in the position so black happily took
and he moved his knight out of the way
attacked upon and we're about to see
black a common theme in this game is he
sort of gets him into positional trouble
he gets himself into some tricky
situations you know this this looks
quite good for white but black is quite
a crafty fella
he found a lot of tactical ways to get
himself out of positional jams and we're
going to see that very soon so he played
b5 very sensible protect your pond
he took opened up the rook very good and
ok can you find the movie black played
in this position so blacks you know just
been sort of outplayed and he's going to
look for a way to really cause some
problems for his opponent you know
really mix up the game really you know
he's going to try to drastically change
the nature of the game to try to get
himself back into the swing of things
so it may or may not have been
objectively the best move here but it's
a very good practical decision was
played here by black so can you see the
combination that black decided to go for
in this game it's really nice this was a
Correspondence game so they presumably
had more time than the class to think
about this position does anyone have any
ideas though
we do still have this really strong
bishop so we are trying to set up some
tactics on this diagonal that's the big
hint
yeah Knight to c4 okay I will take it
94 right so this obviously is the very
tempting move to make it it doesn't
quite work though because I take here I
think the move here was Bishop to c4 and
so it actually looks kind of promising
and this is sort of this is sort of the
idea it doesn't quite work here so this
doesn't look quite good for black but
we'll compare it to it is yeah so even
if it's not quite right it's still it
still might work even in a
correspondence game but in the game he
actually played he is the same idea but
first team started this move Knight to
c6 which so it's a similar sort of
scenario it does sort of get rid of a
weakness for him you just fill them fill
that guy in the other version might also
just equally be good but this the engine
said you do this way or not do it and it
said don't take on e4 right away so well
yeah it's very similar so the idea of
course Knight takes e4 as we sex one
night and he sexed another and then he's
going to pick up your rook your queen
and Knight are attacked so you're forced
to accept this and give up the rook this
way which is okay which may or may not
be exactly the best for black but he
really has gotten himself out of a
predicament he really was sort of
outplayed and then we got this very
strange imbalance where it's two pieces
for an exchange and that's some pawns
it's just very very messy and so when
you're worse you really want to mix up
the position like this because now White
has to really go back to the drawing
board and figure out what he's going to
do here and having the puns there's nice
central pawns for black that's a nice
little plus keeps them nice and safe and
your white played another very good move
Bishop c4 and black played a very
understandable move but it wasn't
correct I think he played a move that's
very tempting white is about to Castle
then you'll be attacking our Bishop on a
one so black simply retreated and again
white now has a concrete way to just end
the game and again it wasn't spotted by
our protagonist it's something that may
come to your mind and it's sort of you
know maybe black is about to Castle
maybe you just gonna play move like
e6000 mission to g7 lady five so this is
obviously a very tempting idea we want
to double attack I will play you six
suppose like a castle okay e6 and then
I'll go like this and hope you don't
have any sacrifices so this actually
isn't it but it's it's definitely a part
of the idea we do have this idea of
taking on f7 now you've been playing as
much book house as I have today this
movement really really obvious so if
you're playing buck house you won't even
think you wouldn't even calculate
anything you just just play this amount
in a heartbeat yeah absolutely I thought
the left one makes me think some people
have figured it out
also he did do this domain that's the
move that he actually played me game you
take on f7 and this ends the game now
this is something you may want to
consider when you're playing this the
obvious idea is we're playing Knight to
g5 but okay it is a correspondence game
so maybe you actually can look at
every variation here and it's okay some
of them are a little bit more difficult
to figure out than others so I don't
know if he actually took a look at this
some of you want to see but you you know
you're given a piece away so you better
make sure your checkmating and every
line here so let's look at a couple King
retreats and let's say okay so this one
is is obviously bad news
due to this work but uh what about this
move what would we play now there's a
mating attack this is yeah just drawing
the line up just go up and yeah you can
give your stuff away but this is it's
not going to end right before yeah a
little bit more testing and difficult is
this move and what I really like to is
the objectively best move is it you're
really really surprising move there is
and I gave everything wins though as
long as you are getting your Queen on
the right diagonal what's funny is the
best move is is actually either c2 or d3
for the Queen and that's really annoying
and defending it doesn't help you very
much just ninety six and it's over so
that's very good just for a laugh maybe
will come up in here too it's also it's
very tempting so you might want to pause
at home this is it's very hard to play
the objectively best move here because
it's matin three I think there's so many
checks and moves that are very very
tempting
the only reason to show this is because
though the best move is funny so I'll
just I'll just give away Queen d5 so
sort of a silent Queen move the you know
threatens all sorts of mates and mates
and okay just you can't stop them all
you can try to stop one but then
I have another I guess you can try to
hear then I have to find the cutest mate
that's difficult
maybe yeah this has to be made - mine
was prettier yeah yeah the only decision
you have to make is Lia what's the
prettiest way to make you from this
position it's tough it's probably a lot
of meeting - ok so again I mean it's
understandable that perhaps it was was
difficult to calculate some of those
variations but it is the sort of thing
you want to look for you're way ahead
and development the King still isn't
safe Black has to do something about the
safety of his King pretty soon and I
guess this is again your chance to
strike while you possibly can but in the
game night g5 which you knows is very
reasonable in its own right all right so
he defended again I go and I hope you
don't have any sacrifices white castled
okay very reasonable and now
d Phi's also what's funny is if you look
up here when he castled it was moved 20
so it says zero zero - zero so you want
to wait til move 10 or 20 to Castle
kingside because your opponent might
think that you Castle queenside because
a zero zero zero and then he's still
confused he thinks you're Kings way over
there
that's good strategy okay so move 20 we
finally see somebody Castle d5 which is
fine perhaps he's going to in the future
think about trying to target this pawn
okay
sensible enough I mean II seven and here
I actually I liked what white decided to
do although I thought he was going to do
it for a slightly different reason
played the move Knight f3 and you might
you know the knight will seem in like
he's doing pretty good on g5 you know
but there's never going to be any
sacrifices now blacks really defended
quite well and I assume that White's
point was he was going to try to control
the e5 square so he I thought he's gonna
play Bishop f4 maybe rook e1 and either
put a bishop here or a knight here
trying to you know get the dark squared
Bishop soph the board and hopefully we
get an attack on the King but we do have
to be careful as white because black is
also going to Castle and then he's going
to use his rooks on this file so that
sort of thing like has his chances here
too so this move for some reason I guess
she's afraid of Bishop to g5 he didn't
have to be but but wait had a different
plan with his knight after rook e1 he is
pretending to have a threat here but
there's no threat and so here black over
reacts to White's threat now white just
put a rock on the same file as a queen
and a king
so it looks like there's going to be
some sort of sacrificing and then I take
your Queen somehow that's what it looks
like but it's not actually true because
if we just waste a move here for a
second and
we think we're brilliant because if you
take you're going to get into a lot of
trouble the joke's on you because now I
clear up d8 and this pin is annoying so
this it's not a real threat so black
really doesn't want to overreact like
this in this position so he perceives a
possible threat but you want to make
sure you're seeing is that actually
truly a threat or do I have some counter
defense because in the game he played
rook to d8 preventing white from
blundering so now White's not going to
go through with that sacrifice they
might otherwise have gone for and more
than that you're also taking a rook it
was very good this is a very decent file
for the RIP half-open file are you going
to come in this time now just goes chill
there all right so he can use that and
he could double his rook so you could
try to get them active and into the game
later on but now that rook is on the
worst Square so that's not going to
happen and this was White's idea he is
going to put his knight on b5 ok it
keeps a lot of pressure on blacks
position is it is it his time already
oh yeah he goes so after Knight to be 5
rook e8 which is not going to be the
best move because now what white does is
he really goes after the C pawn and
we're going to see why this isn't a very
good square for this rook in just a
moment now once again black has sort of
gotten himself into a bad way
positionally you know he he again you
know he sort of he messed up the board
he made it really difficult
you know white didn't play super
accurately and punished them as directly
as he could have and now he's gotten
himself into
positional trouble again because
probably he should just end up playing a
passive Lou of legwork to see eight but
again he's a very very coming guy so he
went for crazy confusing which again
sort of helps him out in a way and again
it's not objectively perfect but the
element of surprise is really blacks
Forte here
Queen b5 so just giving up on the c7
pawn so flex is alright or white says
I'll take it
and now now what was flex point there's
only one moved here so you have to play
accurately here which is funny so when
the game got really technical both of
these players played really well
so the must move here Bishop c3
and again you know it's he's messing up
the board it's starting to get
complicated I take your rook I'm on f2
so you don't have time to win the
exchange on e8 because I'm doing stuff
to you on f2 that you're not going to
like so he took the bishop and the rook
has time now to retreat so we saw him at
the beginning do this Knight maneuver
now he did this rook maneuver but again
the board is so messy that it's becoming
really difficult however this movement
from now on white is just going to play
fantastic chess here so which is funny
when it positionally they didn't play so
well but then when it gets really
technical they both played fantastic so
this next move by white really really
excellent move so I'll give the audience
a chance to play the best move here
because the olive white smoked an hour
or just great
you do have a way of going after this
King I mean he did this to himself early
on
now there's and then he got rid of the
dark-squared bishop
so make as many dark squares red as we
can Bishop h6 this is a very tempting
move I think but okay if I remember
right I play here and then if you take I
take back and this should be okay for
you to but I'm even though you know
again I'm I lost a little bit of
material there I'm trying to give Ernie
a dark squared Bishop because that's a
really powerful piece in this position
so you do want to kind of find a way to
keep him on the board if you're going to
really try to punish black here and why
did find a good way to do it he started
with the move Queen to e5 and it may
look like I'm trying to do this but I
also have the very powerful idea going
to f6 and putting my Bishop on e5 which
is very difficult for black so here King
aged seven and again white did find a
very powerful move the Queen went to f6
and I'm just going to go here you're not
going to like it so that took here
and again here is a moment that are if
you're super technician maybe you can
play this move there's really an awesome
of the white could play here now in the
game white played the obvious move he
put his bishop on e5 so we'll come back
to this in just a second and alright
it's it's a supercomputer move it will
will show off so he went here and now
you have this threat you can't really
move your rook here because I'm taking
this so the only way for black to defend
is to check and then park the Queen on
h6
so this is what happened in the game and
all right this is very good for white as
we'll see however for super accuracy you
could have played the move g4 so this is
the super Pro move the idea is after any
move now we play Bishop e5 and the idea
is after this again g5 so that would
have been the absolute most clinical way
for white to play but okay I mean that's
fair enough to miss that one so okay so
this is what happened he checked went to
h6 side I'm not mated yet and again
super-powerful move from white so this
is really awesome move for the class you
got like 10 seconds at home as much time
as you want
what did white play in this position so
in the game he sacrificed on e6
so let's see what's the point of this I
take your night now be careful here as
white first time I guess we'll just
we'll go through it
he went to e7 the point being that now
when you go back I can take this pawn
with check he went back and okay so this
he also should be really proud of the
next couple of moves here the game lasts
about two more moves here and okay so
this this is really fantastic now if you
think about what black wants to do you
realize he doesn't have all that many
options but I guess to give it away if
it's blacks turn and we saw in that
other immortal game where you really
constricted all of the pieces and it was
the queen that was trying to slide
around and escape in this position the
Queen can go to g5 which is a very hard
concept I think to to pick up on
immediately so here F for super strong
move now the queen is forever in a box
if white gets another turn he's probably
going to play h4 so black decided I'll
plays for myself now maybe sometimes I
can move my queen but white played one
more move and it's very similar to the
first game and then black gave it up
so I okay you can pause at home there's
people coming in so we'll give it away
a4 and remarkably black is in xub swan
there's absolutely nothing you can do
here you can't move the Queen because
this is going to lead to a quick
checkmate or
you can't move either of your rooks if
you make a move like this you know just
like play here and you know acting like
that so you just you just can't move
either of your rooks anywhere because
okay we play here there's you know you
can even try to give your pawns away so
this doesn't change anything if we take
it you can try giving this guy away but
okay opening up this diagonal this is
not going to be good for you so this
also would lead to a quick mate and so
yeah so it's amazing
he's down to exchanges but these bishops
are actually fantastic pieces
none of black's pieces can move they're
all super constrictive so really really
you should be proud of this game it was
sort of a The Immortal YouTube
submission so thank you for sending it
in it was is really pretty especially I
love the final position